welcome to the program the U.S House of
Representatives has given its go ahead
to suspend the nation's debt ceiling
which currently stands at 31.4 trillion
dollars
yeah 314. the Nazar 117.
the bill is passed
it had just finished holding a vote both
Republican Democrat leaders had been
rallying support amongst their parties
in order to ensure that it passed the
bill will now go to the Senate this is
crucial as without the bills Passage
through Congress the country could run
out of money as soon as Monday U.S House
speaker Kevin McCarthy hailed the move
as historic
we didn't just take the money from this
year we took another 20 billion
I think we should get some more border
agents with that 20 billion I think
that's where America would want to see
us go
we capped the ability of growth of
spending in government for the next six
years
we're holding
people accountable
to do the work you're supposed to do as
a member otherwise
cuts across the board
of correspondent Alan Fisher has been
following events uh through uh the day
then of course Alan I suppose as
politicians in the house and and Beyond
breathing a sigh of relief that at least
the first hurdle has been jumped
and certainly the highest hurdle it was
always going to be difficult to get
through a republican house particularly
when there were so many members of the
Republican Party who were saying that
they wanted to see big cuts first of all
in entitlement programs but also in
government spending now there was a deal
reached after discussions between Kevin
McCarthy and Joe Biden and their
negotiating teams and that's the deal
that was put forward on the house floor
Kevin McCarthy is saying that this is a
big success and if you look at the
figures absolutely 314 to 117 but the
real story is behind the number of
people who helped him get through and
that was with 165 Democratic votes and
the big number that he'll be worried
about is 47 Republicans voting no now
Kevin McCarthy you'll remember became
speaker after 15 rounds of voting and he
gave a lot of promises to a lot of parts
of the Republican party to make sure he
landed in that top job the difficulty
now is that many of those 70 21 new
votes are saying that Kevin McCarthy
gave too much away to the Democrats and
he may have to be replaced this speaker
one of the things that he agreed to when
he became speaker was that just one
member of the Republican conference
could call for his removal now it's all
very well him talking in the last few
minutes about two-thirds of the
Republicans voting yes it's the small
one-third that he has to worry about so
what happens now well this bill will go
to the Senate at some point on Thursday
expected to get through there we've
heard from Mitch McConnell who is the
leader of the Republicans in the house
saying he will vote Yes so that's a node
that many people will back him up and
with the the Democrats being in the
majority there that's almost certain to
go through which means this bill will
land on the old Resolute desk in the
white house probably at some point on
Friday and Joe Biden will sign it that
will avoid what has essentially been the
U.S economy running for the last five
months on economic fumes you remember it
was back in January the Jan Yelm the
treasury secretary said the United
States was getting close to a point
where it couldn't pay its bills she said
on June the 5th that money would run out
so if there had been a debt default it
would have caused catastrophic economic
harm in the United States and by
extension through the global economy so
this is a win for the moment for Joe
Biden for Kevin McCarthy and for the U.S
and Global economies but there's still
going to be a few more dramas to play
out but that's for another day on
Capitol Hill for tonight everyone seems
to be celebrating yeah for the moment at
least I'm just wondering that while the
Democrats will make hay about this
particular Victory and whatever happens
in the in the Senate which we assume
will go to the Playbook there are those
Republicans certainly those that want to
be part of that presidential run in 2024
that will want to perhaps take issue
with what's been done here and perhaps
be critical of the way McCarthy has
managed to you might say give the
Democrats a victory
foreign
has in the last half hour or so welcomed
the result in the house but those who
are running for the Republican
nomination with the exception of Donald
Trump have said that they don't think
that this is a very good deal at all so
you're talking about Senator Tim Scott
from North Carolina who will have his
vote in the Senate and also Nikki Haley
who is again from South Carolina Mike
Pence who hasn't yet declared whether or
not he's going to run for the Republican
nomination has said it's a bad deal as
well what is interesting is Donald
Trump's silence he of course is the
Republican front-runner he helped
McCarthy get into the speakership and he
hasn't been saying much at all about
that the many of the the Republicans who
voted no the 71 of them many of them
would probably have made that decision
realizing that this bill will get
through even without their support so
they're able to go back to their
constituency constituencies and say look
I was a no vote in this I think we
should cut spending even more that will
play well with the base but the reality
is that this is a win for Joe Biden and
for Kevin McCarthy even though Joe Biden
said that he wouldn't approve any cuts
that was a negotiating stance right at
the start and he realized he would have
to do something particularly as Kevin
McCarthy held the aces with a
republican-controlled House of
Representatives well for the update
thanks very much Alan Fisher there for
us in Washington DC